we're in investing at the moment we're
in investing right it's all that money I
love this - I don't see very much of it
but actually that's a lie we all do
investing all various different things
mostly food you guys you invest time
even if you don't have a job you have
time everyone has time the same done
time actually and we all missed it now
we're looking at the idea of money and
how it grows which is why more the very
first things you look at is interest now
pause you for a second there and ask you
to finish your sentence for me the
sentence is is so talked about I think
we we seldom stop to think what is this
mean and why does it exist okay so I'm
gonna give you about a minute or two to
finish off this sentence like I know the
way interest means a lot of different
things I mean financially right interest
is what what is it and why does it exist
I want you to put it down a bay but I
expect it will get you know 20 different
answers and that's okay I'm interested
in the different ways that people have
to say it but rather than more gin to
like just formulas and stuff like that I
want us to ground it in what this is all
about
okay so I'll give you a couple minutes
to do that put some thought into it try
and make it I'd love to hear your words
for how you would explain if someone
ever heard of interest which actually
when did you guys first hear of the idea
of interest couple years ago like sort
of either high school definitely in high
school for maybe probably okay um yeah
II know
yeah yeah yeah it's a you know you get
your bank statement every month or
quarter whatever and it's like
congratulations you've earned four and a
half cents of interest whatever that is
okay all right so yeah let's try and
work out so obviously this hasn't doing
something like this is connected to
banks banks banks give interest for some
reason I can't Ali you're suggesting did
you say excess and excess money yep it
has to be paid to to who I missed that
last year to be paid when you're paying
off something okay to pay when you have
a loan when you have it load okay good
okay excellent we did um we did talk
about this last time last week actually
we're talked about when there's money
gonna pay off and then this is extra
they have to pay off we call that
interest does anyone have any other
different ideas okay good all right now
this is really interesting um let me
catch you see if I caught the key words
you said reward you said incentive
before for state forgiving putting your
money in the bank right cuz for saving
for saving with a bang yeah good yeah so
they want you to keep going don't pay
right okay doesn't have anything wildly
different to those ideas there yeah
Nathan last one maybe
I reason to put money in them yep is how
they get money okay okay hold on
I want to push on that a little bit okay
let me see if I got that right you said
that interest is away it's a reason to
go with a certain you know institution
right and if the way they earn money now
I want on a second that seems weird to
me bank's paying money to other people
like us and that's the way they earn
money that sounds like the way they lose
money doesn't it I gotta say you're
wrong I think that's true but how does
that work well that's interesting so if
I if I've got money you know I've got
some I've got an amount of money right
and I can put it in a bank or I could
not put it in a bank right
is it better to put it in the bank or
not it is right but like so they'll give
me interest but I have to pay fees am i
just paying and then getting the same
money back like what's the difference
they are different okay okay now I have
a question for you this is my last
question then I'll give you my
definition okay when you're ready goes
these two definitions and this one was
good these secretly opposite to me don't
they like this is this is bad I know
what I have up this kind of interest
right it's like I've got to pay extra
stuff that's not something I like doing
but this is good I like this I like when
people give me money okay so how is it
that this one idea can look so different
sometimes I like it and sometimes I
don't
okay alright alright so we're getting
other IRD let me give you my definition
okay maybe you want to put this
underneath yours okay this is not like a
textbook definition or anything like
that but I think it'll help you
understand what's going on
I am the best way to understand interest
is interest is I call interest the cost
of money hold on a second that's a weed
idea it seems like you're just saying
the cluster of costs or the money of
money what does that even mean okay
here's what I mean
all right let's um you know you're a
teacher when the biggest bill you can
get out your wallet it's a $5 okay now
here's some money
all right now I I I'm in possession of
this money at the moment okay and okay
now I could put this money in the bank
good night okay now if I put it in the
bank right I should have bought some
glue take me here if I put it in the
bank to the bank right now here's the
problem right while the money is in the
bank I can't use it because they've got
it not me
that makes sense like I can't I can't go
and spend this on because I'm because I
because I want to do right now I can't I
can't buy the dough not if the bank's
got my money right and in fact not just
that not only can I not do stuff with
the money but the bank can't do stuff
with the money and actually it's not
just my five dollars right it's all
these other hundreds and thousands of
people who've all put their money in
through the bank right tons of cash in
here okay and they can get one do things
with this money right it's got its got
power yeah making go invest they can buy
a business which makes money or they can
get off offshore venture or so like that
which can earn revenue for them yeah
ah yes okay so here's the idea if I'm
giving them money right I'm actually
doing them a favor right they've got all
this money and they can do cool stuff
with it and earn revenue right it's like
well I'm not gonna lend you my money for
free I'm gonna expect something back
I'll expect a reward or an incentive for
you know letting you hold on to my money
for this amount of time letting you have
access to it okay no that's that's this
idea that's why we get paid money right
well what's this
what kinds of things would we get loans
for examples a house a car is this good
okay so how does this work right let's
go with let's go with the car okay
suppose you buy your car really bad
here's my car okay
I suppose I gone buy this car right but
I can't pay the whole thing I could come
pay I can't afford the whole thing right
now what I kind of called the whole
thing cuz all I've got five dollars
right now okay so I go buy it now who
paid for the car being that all I had
was this five dollars will the bank pay
for it right so well yeah maybe maybe I
put down a huge deposit guys right now
what's happened I'm now in possession of
this car right how much does a car cost
these days anyway 15,000 20,000 now then
giving this car to me so now I've got
this car and this car can it can make
money can earn revenue for me I can use
it to like to do a job to i transport
things around it's like I got money it
just happens to be in the form of a car
right now okay so if I've been given the
bank is giving me this they're like
we're not gonna give you that for free
just like I'm not gonna give the bay my
money for free right Megan expects stuff
back okay so that's why they'll charge
me interest they want to give me
interest they'll charge me interest okay
so can you see what's the difference
between these two it's about the
direction of where the money's going
right does this make sense so excess
money to be paid
you have a loan see that word there but
it means they are giving me something
give me money or a car or a house with
some like that now I've got it so I've
got to pay for the privilege that's the
cost of that money yeah usually it be
something or sometimes it's even more
sometimes maybe 50% depends on your bike
whereas this is where money goes in the
other direction sometimes we give money
to banks and so we charge them interest
interest is kind of like our fees that
we give to them they're like well money
money costs right so if you're gonna
hold on to it I better pay you so much
and that's what we call interest yeah
it's exactly right there are big
differences right and it depends a lot
on what you what you buy the terms on
which you're going to repay it and that
kind of thing for instance what's an
interest rate these days let's call five
okay depending on the money I borrowed
for instance I can borrow money with
this okay now that's not gonna no one's
gonna pay right now here's the thing if
I borrow money on this credit card so
I'm getting money now right so someone's
getting so I'm gonna have to pay the
cost of that money okay it's not nice
try
smoke five percent does anyone know what
a credit card interest rate is about its
frequently 20 plus sometimes up to 30 if
you've got a bad deal right just
interesting why isn't it
but there's interest and in this
interest I'll let you ever think about
it okay there's the idea okay